morning we start with some breaking news
from Ukraine we're hearing that Adam in
a russian-controlled region has been
blown up there's warnings of Water
Rising to critical levels within five
hours and evacuations are taking place
as we speak the dam on the danipro river
is part of the kokova hydroelectric
power plant and is 153 kilometers from
zapparitzia nuclear plant overnight
Ukraine held progress in fighting in the
East while Russia is claiming it has
thwarted an attempt by Ukraine to launch
an offensive in Donetsk well Alex is
standing by for us this morning uh in De
nipro Alex what more do we know good
morning
absolutely huge news overnight and
pictures already coming out of the
breaching of the dam initially Russia
denied that it had been affected both
sides are blaming each other certainly
it is going to cause a huge amount of
problems and looking at how much of it
has been breached they're expecting
certainly the Russians are saying 80
settlements are affected the ukrainians
have already said that at least 10
villagers should immediately Evacuate
the river massive Waterway cuts across
Right Through To Hell territories on the
Left Bank is Ukrainian territory
including hair salon city which you saw
our own Alex Rossi being the first
reporter in there when it was liberated
by the ukrainians back in November but
the dam has been held by Russia and the
other side the other Bank of the river
is under Russian control including this
crucial Dam has been held by Russia
since February 2022.
um if it is um if it floods as it very
much looks like it's going to with both
sides those people in control of the
areas
urging people to evacuate the Ukrainian
police have put out messages on the
telegram channels saying that in five
hours it's going to reach critical level
they should grab everything they can and
try and save their lives including vital
documents pets anything emergency
supplies that they need to get out of
the area
crucially though it also supplies water
to the zaparisha nuclear power plant to
the North and the Crimea Peninsula to
the South which is under Russian control
so it is going to have a dramatic effect
not only on the possibly the cooling
plants in in the separation you nuclear
power plant but also the Water Supplies
to the Crimea Peninsula this is all
coming at a time when the ukrainians
have long
um expressed their desire to launch a
counter offensive that yesterday there
was lots of propaganda from both sides
claims from both sides with the Russians
saying that they had blown up a 16 tanks
and killed nearly 300 Ukrainian soldiers
and one of their probes and in the start
of what they said was the Ukrainian
counter-offensive the ukrainians in the
meantime have issued lots of videos
including hacking into the Crimean
television and radio Services
urging everyone to be quiet and to
maintain their silence and in indeed the
Ukrainian military said they will not be
announcing when they are launching any
counter offenses so it's very difficult
to know whether it has been launch but
certainly this is is going to detract a
lot of attention and Emergency Services
the president of Ukraine has ordered an
emergency meeting of his National
Security Council and they have urged the
Ukrainian authorities have urged both
people living on both sides of the banks
of the river to evacuate as soon as
possible okay for now thank you thanks a
lot
oh well our International correspondent
John Sparks reports now on what we know
about plans for the Ukrainian offensive
the ukrainians have been preparing for
months for a spring offensive that's
shifting to the summer
and the pressures building as they seek
to reclaim their lands
but in this slick looking video produced
by Ukraine's military they tell us
they'll fight where and when they see
fit
plans love silence says the caption
there'll be no announcement about the
start
yet both sides are fighting and the
Russian military spokesman has decided
to call it
the enemy has launched a large-scale
offensive without success he said
we've seen claim and counterclaim in the
past 24 hours Rebel Fighters saying
they're in possession of villages in
Russia's belgarod region while the
Russians say they destroyed a Ukrainian
unit in kuzima there are claims the
ukrainians have taken burkhifka near Bak
moot while the Russians say they've
killed up to 425 Ukrainian troops in
southern Donetsk so the
counter-offensives began says Russia but
the experts aren't so sure I think what
we're seeing is what I would Define as
probing tax uh along the front line to
identify uh the kind of force that um
the ukraines will be faced with
um the the size and the type of Russian
forces that are defending those those
areas the Russians say a large-scale
attack is underway in South Donetsk and
Sky's data and forensic unit have
verified a series of videos from the
area all published in the last 24 hours
here we see tanks in close combat near
the village of Novo darifka
and eight kilometers Northeast in the
same area we've pinpointed footage
released by the Russian defense Ministry
where a number of military vehicles are
targeted
but we haven't seen evidence of a major
thrust by the ukrainians along with the
use of Western tanks like the leopard or
the Challenger
president
thank you very much what we have seen is
the UK's foreign secretary James
cleverly in Kiev where he reassured his
hosts of Britain's continued support
when we made the commitment publicly
that we would continue backing you
and your country
until you are victorious in your
self-defense we meant it and Senior
officials in Ukraine now say they are
moving to offensive operations the tempo
of war is rising John Sparks Sky News
well that was James cleverley in Ukraine
um yesterday well a little earlier
Justin in fact James cleverly speaking
uh wants more reaffirming the UK's
support for Ukraine
we have always made it uh clear that we
support Ukraine's self-defense and of
course the decisions about how Ukraine
conducts that self-defense are rightly
decisions which are made by Ukraine's
leadership we want to see this war come
to a conclusion quickly and it has to
come to a conclusion which is fair which
is right for the people of Ukraine and
of course is a conclusion which
reinforces rather than undermines the UN
Charter and the concept of sovereignty
and territorial integrity